Hello.
Hey, so, yeah, I kind of wanted to give a
different talk about some other stuff, but
I wasn't ready, so this is a make-up talk.
It's been some years since Node came out,
and it's kind of stabilised, and it's a thing,
and it's kind of going into its direction.
I thought I would look back on it and tell
you what I think about Node.
So, sorry, I'm a little nervous.
Excuse my wavering voice.
Right, some background.
I created Node and managed it through its
initial development for a couple of years,
and, my goal, as you may know was really around
IO, and doing event-driven IO in JavaScript.
I think that focus was really important in
2009 for getting server-side JavaScript off
the frowned, because, as we know now, JavaScript
is sing-threaded, and like - I'm sorry.
And - sorry, lost my train of thought.
JavaScript is single-threaded, blah, blah,
blah, that allowed Node to succeed.
I felt that Node was doing well in the IO
department.
Like we had protocol supports, like HTTP,
and HTTPS, and we ported Node to windows using
a nice systems calls IOCP, and we were running
on Linux, Mac, and it had a relatively small
core.
I mean, it kind of got out of hand a little
bit, but it was okay.
It has a stable API, MPM was out, and there
were people adding modules.
I was like, "This project is done now."
So wrong!
Right, obviously, this is a tremendous effort
to keep Node running on everybody's machines
as it does today, and keep it updated with
JavaScript, and fix the issues with it, and
many people have been involved in this effort,
many of them are here.
And I'm sorry, I'm probably being leaving
out many important people.
I personally was kind of done with Node, and
went on to do other.
It's only really in the last six months that
I've started using it heavily again.
Largely because Go came out, and I was interested
in servers, and doing fast servers, and, Go
is a better language for doing Fast servers.
There was no need for me to be using Node.
But, I think Node is quite nice.
JavaScript is really quite nice.
In particular, dynamic languages with very
nice.
And they're nice for certain things, I should
say.
I think if you're building a server, and you
want to really control every aspect of it,
absolutely, you want it to be statically typed,
but in scientific computing, for example,
there is a lot of one-off calculations, you're
kind of typing into a Jupiter notebook, and
you really don't want to hit a type error
at that point.
You're just trying to plot something, right?
There's a time and place for dynamic languages.
Prototyping things is another situation.
Like you want to move very fast, you don't
want to worry about what the abstractions
are, you just want to be dynamic.
JavaScript, obviously, I mean maybe there's
many people that don't agree, but here they
do.
It is the best dynamic language.
So, right, using Node is kind of like nails
on chalkboard to me at times, just because
I see the bugs that I introduced that aren't
really bugs at this point, they're just how
it works, but they are bugs.
And they were design mistakes made that just
cannot be corrected now because there's so
much software there that uses it, and I don't
know, it offends my sensibilities.
It could have been much nicer.
So, one regret would be that I didn't stick
with promises.
So, promises were added very early, and I
foolishly removed them not very long after
with the idea that we should be minimal and
promises introduced an extra object into every
callback, and I could see my reasoning at
the time, but had that gone differently, it
might have made the ecosystem around building
asynch await stuff happen faster unclear.
It is an alternate history that we will never
know.
Maybe it was a good thing that promises were
removed because it allowed the ecosystem to
develop their own tools, and we found the
right abstraction.
But, I have often thought that I wish I had
left that in.
That was a rash decision.
Did I say all of this?
Yes.
Another regret is security, because JavaScript
is a very secure sandbox, unlike Python, right?
Unfortunately, in Node, we just bounce to
everything and is there is zero security.
You run a Node programme, you have access
to all sorts of system calls.
That was really a missed opportunity to be
able to make a sever side run time that could
potentially be secured in certain situations.
Obviously, if you wanted to give access to
the disk, then people are going to be able
to exploit the disk, but there are certain
situations where you want to run a programme
outside of the web browser, but you don't
want to to access the disk or network.
For example, a linter.
It would be nice to download the massive codebase
that Lint is and run it without it taking
over my computer - which it could.
Yes.
Yes, probably biggest regret is the build
system.
Such a pain.
Build systems are very, very difficult and
very, very important to building projects.
Node uses this thing called jip.
If you're writing a module that links to a
C library, you use this thing called jip to
compile that C library and link it into Node,
right?
Jip is this thing that Chrome used to use,
but Chrome, like abandoned jip for this other
tool called GN several years later.
We couldn't have predicted that, but that's
what happens.
Now it has been many years since that happened,
and Node is the sole user of jip.
It is a funky interface, a JSON file, but
it's in Python.
It's very terrible.
Node has several wrappers around this.
One of them is called node.jip.
It is layers upon layers of unnecessary complexity.
V8 doesn't build with jip any more.
It has a jip wrapper to support node, there
is just so much unnecessary complex technology
there, and, gentlemen, frankly, I think this
is one of the biggest failures of the Node
technical leadership.
It should be dealt with.
So, I think yes, I am not sure which direction
would be the right way to go at this point.
It's a difficult problem.
There's a lot of software to support, but
I do think that I kind of made a kind of rash
decision in thinking that everybody should
compile their extension modules.
We could have gone with a foreign function
interface, which doesn't require any compiling
necessarily, although you have to have your
dependencies there, but I think this could
have been a much more natural and easy interface
for people who want to link to system libraries,
and many people suggested this to me, namely
Bryan Cantrell, but I totally ignored them.
And, yes, LBUV moved to autotools which is
unacceptable and regrettable.
You know who you are!
[Laughter].
I didn't do that.
That's a regret for somebody else.
[Laughter].
So, right been.
Another thing.
Package JSON.
It is like the life blood of JavaScript at
this point.
But, you know, at some point, it wasn't, and
Isaac of MPM fame more or less defined it,
although there might have been some sort of
specification, and I largely sanctioned it,
and made it popular by allowing require in
Node semantics to look into package JSON and
look through files.
This makes package JSON necessary for programmes,
for Node programmes where it was not before,
and then ultimately, I included MPM into Node
which made MPM made them the standard Node
distribution service, and yes, so, I have
this problem about the little abstract, but
in your JavaScript programme, right, if you
require some module, that doesn't completely
specify what that module is.
It also needs to be defined in your pack age
JSON, that is part of the resolution algorithm,
like, which version it is and what not, in
order to install it, and you also have this
Node modules folder which does the modules
resolution.
So, you know, kind of linking to a package
requires a lot of systems here, a lot of components
that is not - what's that?
I cloud.
Urgh.
All right.
So, yes, I mean, pack age JSON, the problem
I have with it is that it gives this rise
to a concept of a module as this directory
of files, where that wasn't really a concept
before.
Like we had JavaScript files.
On the web, we had JavaScript files, and you
can script-tag include them all over the place.
There's, like, thing.
There is no module pack age as there is in
MPM.
It is not a necessary abstraction.
Package JSON has all this unnecessary noise
in it.
Like why am I filling this out?
I feel like a bookkeeper.
This is unnecessary stuff so do when all I'm
trying to do is link to a library.
I will get to relative URLs.
Of course, Node modules get very big because
it kind of has this vendoring by default semantics
where modules are installed locally into your
project folder, so you tend to have, if you
have multiple projects, it gets big.
This was my idea.
I regret it.
The whole algorithm or resolving module names
is just wildly complex.
It is kind of been added to over time in ways
that are regrettable.
I feel like the vendored by default, idea
behind Node modules which is what I was going
for there was kind of had good intentions,
that we know exactly what we are linking to.
It was supposed to be explicit, but, in practice,
like a Node path type thing, a Python path
type thing would have worked.
You set an environmental variable.
It just deviates greatly from how browsers
do stuff, and it's my fault, and I'm very
sorry, and, unfortunately, it is impossible
to undo now.
Also, this whole thing where you don't include
the extension in the require module.
Why?
It's like needlessly non-explicit.
You now have to, like, probe the file system
for different things.
Did you mean .just, .ts?
No, just writing the ... extension in there!
[Applause].
I'm glad you guys agree with me, because there
is still some debate about this stuff.
People like the extension list thing.
It is cleaner.
Like no!
Yes.
Said all that.
Also, index.js.
I'm sorry.
I thought it was cute.
There's index.html.
I thought when you include a directory, it
would look up index.js.
This was needlessly introduced.
What I've come to learn now that I'm age willing
is that, like, when you're designing a programme,
there are things that you think might be cute
to add in.
You always regret those.
If those are unnecessary and simply cute,
like don't do them.
My problems with Node aren't so much around
the IO, and honestly, I like Node.
I like programming in it.
I think it is relatively nice.
It is Unix-y but my problems are more to do
with the module system and how it manages
user code.
And I think this is largely because, when
I was making Node, like it was very focused
on getting this IO stuff.
I was nerding out hard-core on e pull and
the module system was essentially an afterthought
that got added on as users needed this stuff,
and it is reflected in how Node works now.
So, yes, with that in mind, I was writing
up this talk.
It seemed negative.
I thought this is shitty to come you mean
in front of people and complain about stuff
without giving like you should offer some
sort of solution, or like at least a prototype
of how things might be differently, or how
Node might be differently if you designed
it today, and all I say is that don't try
out this code.
It's very, very unusable at this moment.
It does not do anything.
Unless you're well versed in LLDB, you should
not try building it, but that said, you might
want to check out - Dano is a secure typescript
runtime on V8 working on the tag line.
Not so sure about that this is a new piece
of software, one month old.
This is my riffing on what I think would be
a nice server time runtime these days.
Event IO is taken for granted.
We have to do that.
What else is important?
For one, security.
It would be nice to utilise that JavaScript
is a sandbox.
By default no write access, and that users
can then opt into various access.
So, if you want to allow it to access the
network, you do dash dash allow network.
This allows people in situations, you have
some code that you want to run without giving
it much access to the system that you're you
are running on, and this allows you to do
that via the fact that JavaScript is a runtime.
We don't bind or allow the system to reach
into the operating system.
All system pulls are done through a message
past.
There's a single entry point where it's found
all over the place, it's very difficult to
keep track of what is happening in those single
entry points, and this has caused a lot of
problems trying to find the domains, and [sound
feed distorted].
I thought for many years, , having this ... thing
would be nice.
Here's a pig description of what it is.
You have like the deno process which is written
in Go at the moment, although I'm debating
whether that is the right choice, and you
have V8 running there inside of it, and there
is the send-and-receive calls that are bound
into V8, and it can send and receive proto-buff
messages.
They're array buffers.
There is a dispatcher that kind of like sends
out messages to various different modules,
so these modules can kind of on both sides
of the kind of privileged and unprivileged
boundary sync up, and the Go side can handle
the system calls and return your request for
a set time out into a sleeper, whatever, and,
in V8, you have a similar module system.
Inside of V8 itself, you have the typescript
compiler, built into the whole executable.
I love type typescript.
It is the best thing.
I don't know the people who did this work
at Microsoft, but, man, it is very pragmatic
and well done and approachable, and I just
love the fact that you can start hacking in
normal JavaScript and just slowly kind of
build your project up.
This was one of the goals of Dart.
Do you know Dart?
Total failure!
Very good intentions and cool, but obviously,
a failure at this point.
Typescript took a totally different approach
to the problem and worked completely in JavaScript
and I think you know, solved it in a way that
is satisfying many people, so, if you have
not been using typescript, like please check
it out.
I want this thing to do typescript, because
I like it.
Also, I want to simplify the module system,
so screw all this stuff about how Node modules
work, and that.
I can't be compatible with Node, like otherwise
you end up building Node.
There's no attempt at compatibility with existent
software.
This is mostly a thought expert, right.
I think it would be cute if you just import
via where the source code came from, as you
do in the web, right?
There's a source file there.
You link to that source file and now you've
linked it into your programme.
If it is a relative, you electric do a relative
include.
You should obviously provide an extension.
You might be wondering, "I don't want this
source code changing out from under me, this
seems fishy."
Well, it won't.
So the first time you do this, if you don't
have the URL loaded, then it downloads it,
and it caches it somewhere.
And, then it never updates that again.
When you run it again, it is still using the
same code.
However, you can do a --reload as you do in
the browser - that's my Control R hand signal.
It has a similar semantics where it will do
a hard reload of all the cache files.
And, yes, you can do vendoring and stuff by
giving it a different place where it downloads
these files.
I think this is viable.
Typescript compiler built into it, blah, blah,
blah, Deno hooks into ... yes, so, I mean,
typescript should work out the box, and obviously
JavaScript should still work out of the box
but that's trivial because typescript is a
super set of JavaScript, and yes.
At the moment, it its start-up time is slow
at one second which is completely unacceptable.
However, I'm working on using V8 snapshots
to snapshot the entire compiler, and plus
other optimisations that have to be done.
I'm confident it can be improved greatly.
And so, Deno also, I don't like shipping all
of these files, I hate that, I think it should
be a single executable, so it should be an
executable that doesn't link to too many things
so you can just download the executable and
run it.
And yes, just generally take advantage of
the fact that we are in the future now, and
things are great.
In the build process in Node, there is a complicated
set-up of defining require, requiring the
files, build them in a bundle, but now we
have parcel, which is really great, by the
way, so, what I can do is I can write kind
of a normal Node programme structure to be
the internal systems of Deno and then run
Parcel on it, use it, and that will use Node's
module resolution scheme and stuff but now
I have a single bundled JavaScript file and
I can dump that into V8.
That makes the whole process of building this
thing much simpler.
Yes, and, great infrastructure exists now
in native code, right?
Part of Node was writing a web server.
We spent a lot of time on the HTTP parser.
There's no need to do that.
That's done at this point.
If this ends up being Go, then you link into
the HTTP routines which are super good or
maybe use Rust or C++, and, in the situation,
there are easy ways to link into high-level
code, high-level native code these days, and
I think that that really ease s the job of
this thing.
Yeah.
And so miscellaneous things like just die
immediately when you have an unhandled promise.
Who has ever wanted to, "Maybe I will add
a catch handler later?
I don't want this to die immediately."
No, it should die as soon as it gets an error.
Should support top-level - but it's not hard.
And be browser compatible.
In Node, I remember thinking like window is
a really dumb variable name for the global
scope.
It is not a window, it should be called "global".
Yes, I don't know.
That was a mistake because now we have this
whole, like, incompatibility issue with the
browser.
Where Deno with overlap with the browser,
it should should use the browser semantics,
the browser functions, and what not.
Check it out maybe.
I don't know.
It is a prototype.
It was just - yes, I think I'm mildly happy
with it so far.
Yes.
If you have any comments or questions, I guess
you can't ask me now, but please email me,
and, yeah, first person to implement an HTTP
server gets a star!
I still have three minutes left.
So thanks for having me here.